i could say for me i come from
an ordinary to be honest uh quite a poor
background really and um
when i was a kid i just wanted to make
money it's hard being poor you get
judged from being poor you know i didn't
want to be poor number i wanted to make
some money and you know i thought i was
smart and i could do it you know
so um i went into the city but the truth
is because of
the kind of backgrounds i come from i
didn't what i thought was a lot of money
was not what they was making the city
they was making a lot more money
in the city you know what i mean and um
i remember like my first bonus day like
what i was expecting and for me in my
head that was like
wow and then um when i went into the
room
the boss man he was a big guy i remember
he had this little piece of paper on the
table
i looked at it and i was like is it that
number and he was like
yes that number and i remember i
literally said wow that's a big number
not
because for me like the first thing that
that made me that come to my head was
was my dad basically
my dad worked for the post office for i
think 35 years
and when i was a young kid he used to
start work really early in the morning
i used to leave home at like 5 30 or
something my mom
used to wake us up and the train used to
run right past my bedroom
and then my dad would look out the
window and try and see my dad on the way
in you know and um
he was up like before you know early
before the sun come up every day
going in and he never made a lot of
money you know
and we was never we never really had
that much
but he was up every day 5am 5am going in
going in
and um it's funny like
i was there in the room and i should
have been super happy
but the first thing i thought was my dad
every day up 5am you know what i mean
going into work and then thinking i was
i think i was 22 and i was making like
maybe more than 10 times my dad made
them one year
and it was just it was just a madness it
was a madness
i i went back to my desk and i i was
just like in shock and the guy next time
these guys thought it was funny
they thought i was funny like me coming
in like sort of like a street kid they
thought it was funny
the guy next was like just go take a
moment take a moment
and um listen of course like i'm super
grateful i know what it's like to
have money i'm super grateful that i've
got money now and i'm secure
um but it's difficult like
to be like fully happy when you when
you've grown up and you've seen how hard
some people are working
to make so little one to struggle and
you know that as a 22 year old you can
walk into the city and make this
10 times that so yeah i'm conflicted
because on the one hand look it's mad
importance
i know there's people from worlds where
that's not a lot of money
because i've seen both sides of the coin
you know um
so i know that there's people making
that money and i think kids from my sort
of background have every right to make
what their what those guys are making
and to get financial security and to get
property but at the same time when
people like my dad and my friends dads
are working so hard and getting so
little it's hard not to feel that
that that's that there's unfairness
there anyone getting involved in that
world of online trading online
foreign exchange trading forex betting
that is a dangerous world a very very
dangerous world um
you know i do some of this online and i
don't mean that as an endorsement
but you know people get dragged into
using trading strategies they're sitting
there every day buy buy buy sell sell
sell the truth is
the vast majority of people that do that
they lose money basically it's gambling
basically it is gambling um it's not
really that different
to you going in and doing the slot
machines or just betting on the sports
but because it's for an exchange trading
people sort of think it's investing but
the truth is if you don't know what
you're doing
if you don't have a really solid handle
that is gambling gambling can ruin lives
it can ruin families so
anyone out there doing that please be
careful don't gamble more than you can
afford to lose make sure you know what
you're doing
um don't be fooled into thinking you're
a big shot trader if you're not
but at the same time look i fully
understand it i know how difficult it is
to make money from working i know how
difficult is to make money from working
and then at the same time like i say
i've been
in a city and i've been i've studied at
oxford you know and i see people born
into money
that have millions in them and then i
see people working i can't get anything
and then as people see people like me
going to the city essentially gambling
and making a lot of money or not
like realistically we live in a world
now where the only way
to get rich is to be born rich or to
gamble you know so so people are at home
and they want to gamble but the truth is
it's dangerous it's dangerous you can
lose you can lose a lot of money and for
a lot of people that's money they can't
afford to lose so
i understand it but the truth is for
most people who don't have
some sort of advantage some sort of
special knowledge is gambling it's
dangerous
be careful so
i think you need to understand exactly
how i made money in the city all right
my job i started working in 2008 that
was when a big crash happened all right
my job was essentially to predict when
will there be a recovery okay and in
2008 everyone all the economists thought
it would happen next year 2009
but that didn't happen 2009 everybody
said next year 2010
that didn't happen right in 2010
everyone was like okay well it'll take
one more year 2011
that was mind-blowing to me right i
studied at london school of economics
we thought everybody understood what was
happening then i went to work in a city
with a bunch of millionaires who get
paid six-figure salaries sometimes
more to understand what's gonna happen
and they're wrong every year
for me that was amazing but also it was
opportunity because if these guys the
best paid guys
if they don't know what's happening then
it's me i can do it i'm as good as
anyone else right
if i can figure out why there's no
recovery then i can make i can be a
millionaire basically so
i was obsessed with this idea why is
there no recovery why is there no
recovery
and i came to the conclusion that all
this money that was getting poured into
the economy it wasn't going to ordinary
people it was going to rich people
now unlike most people in that world i
could see
that there's a difference between what
ordinary people do and what rich people
do
ordinary people spend their money rich
people save it if you give millions to
the richest all you're going to do is
push up asset prices
stock prices house prices you're not
going to make the economy recover
now if that's what's happening then that
means there will be no economic recovery
when i realized that it was like a penny
dropping i went back to the desk i put a
massive bet on there will never be an
economic recovery
by the end of that year 2011 when i was
24 i was the most profitable trader at
citibank in the world
by betting that there would never be an
economic recovery all right
you know and at work that's worked every
year since right but can you imagine
like what kind of
situation that puts me in one you are
one of the best traders going
you're making loads of money and it's
because you're betting there will never
be an economic recovery
and then at the end of the year i get
paid a lot of money and it's just like
well done do it again
but i mean how many times can you get
paid
a load of money for betting the world's
going to be terrible forever before you
start thinking
maybe i've got some sort of obligation
to at least try and tell people
that this economic problem is serious
and forever and not getting better
you know i've said it enough times i
come from an ordinary background people
like my parents like my friends that the
kids i grew up with
they are the guys that are getting hurt
here and the future generations are not
going to have a chance
if we don't do something about this and
look i'm not pretending to be an angel
i'm not my humble gandhi i made my money
but i made my money by betting on and
understanding that the economy will be
weak forever
you know if you knew that your next-door
neighbor's house
was gonna burn down you gotta tell them
right well that that is what i'm seeing
this is an economy that is gonna burn
down if we don't do anything
and i could sit in one of these
skyscrapers in canary wharf and make a
million pounds a year
but then you know the economy will still
burn down and what am i going to tell my
kids i'm going to sell well i made my
money better and the economy would burn
down
did you tell anyone did you try and do
anything about it you know what i mean
like
listen i made my money you know i'm not
an angel but at the same time
i care about this country and the people
of this country and the world and what
happens to the economy and
if i make money betting that the economy
is going to break
i for why at least have an obligation to
try and tell people listen
this economy is gonna break it's
breaking i understand how i understand
how to fix it
if nobody listens and maybe i'll go back
but i've gotta try
you